a mystery still unfolding in nashville
tennessee
federal investigators are combing for
clues in an area popular with tourists
in the city's downtown after a
recreational vehicle
exploded there early on christmas day
the blast which police believe was
intentional damaged dozens of buildings
and injured three people before the
explosion the rv blared a warning
that it was loaded with explosives
wow investigators say they discovered
what they believe
are human remains near the blast site
mola lenghi begins our coverage from
downtown nashville mola good morning
good morning enrique police have not yet
been able to determine if those human
remains belong to someone who's actually
in the rv
or perhaps just a passerby but here in
nashville
that explosion has rattled more than
just these city buildings
the quiet of christmas morning shattered
just after 6
30 a chilling message blaring from the
rv seconds before
it exploded
[Music]
the blast could be felt miles away
it shattered windows shook buildings and
sent a tower of black smoke high above
downtown nashville
we do believe that the explosion was an
intentional act
police were initially called to the
scene to investigate a report of gunfire
but when they arrived they
encountered the rv warning anyone nearby
to evacuate
officers upon hearing that decided to
evacuate the buildings
nearby so they began knocking on doors
making announcements having
emergency communication communicate with
everyone to get
people safe one tourist was in her hotel
room a half mile away
when the explosion happened we were
sitting in bed and we thought it was a
thunder
real long roll and then the window
started shaking
so we figured well that's not thunder
police have released this photo of the
rv
which was parked near an att
transmission building the blast
caused communications outages and forced
flights at nashville's airport to be
grounded but so far
there is no known motive and no suspect
overnight the usually
bustling streets of music city were
deserted mayor john cooper declaring a
state of civil emergency
and enacting a curfew through sunday as
the investigation here begins
cooper says it's also time to heal we
hate having to prove that we're
resilient one more time
but we're going to do it and we're going
to rebuild second avenue
we're going to catch the people that did
this we're going to get our state and
federal partners to help us do that
we're going to celebrate our
heroes which are first responders that
went and saved lives this morning and
now
you're going to have investigators who
are going to catch the people who did
this
well the three people who were injured
are said that they're going to be okay
but you heard the mayor say that this
has been a rough year
for nashville a city that relies so much
on tourism and the tourism economy but
eureka the nashville convention
and visitors corporation is contributing
twenty five thousand dollars
towards a reward for information to
solve this mystery all right moba
lengthy force in nashville thank you